ahora veremos un circuito que se conoce
como divisor de voltaje y es el nombre
que se le da a un circuito sencillo
compuesto por dos resistencias en serie
vamos a dibujarlas aquí y esto es un
sobrenombre en el sentido de que
solamente es un patrón que observamos al
analizar circuitos y veremos cuál es
este patrón tenemos dos resistencias en
serie y suponemos que hay un voltaje
aquí conectado de esta manera a esto se
le llama un voltaje de entrada les
llamaremos b y el punto que se encuentra
entre las dos resistencias y el punto
que se encuentra típicamente abajo de la
segunda resistencia entre estos dos
puntos mediremos un voltaje que
llamaremos bs de voltaje de salida así
que tenemos un patrón básico con estas
resistencias en serie alimentadas con un
voltaje en los extremos de ambas
resistencias y queremos conocer el
voltaje a través de una de estas
resistencias ahora vamos a desarrollar
una expresión para esto
vamos a poner etiquetas a nuestras
resistencias aquí tenemos a r 1 y aquí a
r 2 y ahora sí vamos a desarrollar una
expresión para esto vamos a decir que
por aquí pasa una corriente que vamos a
llamar y y vamos a suponer que la
corriente que pasa por acá es 0 ninguna
corriente sale de este circuito lo que
significa que por supuesto la corriente
que pasa por esta otra resistencia
también es y así que la corriente
continua hasta abajo y ahora queremos
una expresión que nos diga qué es bs en
términos de estas dos resistencias de
aquí sin olvidar nuestro voltaje de
entrada vamos a hacerlo vamos a usar la
ley de ohm para escribir una expresión
para cada una de estas resistencias que
tenemos en serie aquí escribimos la ley
de ohm nos dice tb es igual a i por r en
nuestro caso específico de el voltaje de
entrada es igual ahí porque pues la
combinación en serie de nuestras
resistencias r1 y r2 y la combinación en
serie de las resistencias es su suma así
que tenemos aquí r uno más r 2 vamos a
despejar la corriente y es igual a b
entre r uno más r2 ahora vamos a
escribir una expresión que nos relacione
ds y ds o el voltaje de salida sólo
depende de r2 y de esta corriente de
aquí así que el voltaje de salida es
igual a y por r2 despejamos ahí y nos
dice que es igual al voltaje de salida
entre r 2
y ahora tenemos dos expresiones para iu
y como en nuestro circuito hicimos esta
suposición de que no sale corriente
alguna del circuito estas dos corrientes
son la misma así que igualamos estas
expresiones entre sí bs entre r 2 es
igual a b entre r1 r2 ahora tomamos a r2
y lo ponemos del otro lado de la
igualdad tenemos que r s es igual a b
por r 2 entre r 1 más r 2 y a esto le
llamamos la expresión del divisor de
voltaje nos da una expresión para el
voltaje de salida en términos del
voltaje de entrada y la proporción de
las resistencias las resistencias
siempre son números positivos así que
esta fracción siempre va a ser menor a 1
lo que significa que el voltaje de
salida siempre va a ser un poco menor
que el voltaje de entrada y esto es
ajustable modificando los valores de las
resistencias
así que es un circuito muy útil
hagamos algunos ejemplos y vamos a crear
un divisor de voltaje para que podamos
practicar esto aquí tenemos 2 k oms o
2011 y aquí abajo tenemos 6.000 oms o 6
k oms y vamos a conectarlas a una fuente
de energía que luce así que es de 6
volts
vamos a medir la salida aquí la salida
de nuestro divisor de voltaje y aquí
tenemos de salida encontremos esto
usando la expresión del divisor de
voltaje el voltaje de salida es igual al
voltaje de entrada que es 6 volts
multiplicado por la proporción de las
resistencias r 2 es 6 kilos dividido
entre dos kilos más 6 kilos y vean que
las casas se cancelan esto siempre
ocurre esto es igual a 6 por 6 entre 2 6
es 8 y si hacemos los cálculos nos queda
que el voltaje de salida es igual a 4.5
volts y esto es un divisor de voltaje si
recuerdan al inicio nosotros supusimos
que la corriente que salía por acá era
igual a cero si la corriente que tienen
por acá es realmente pequeña casi cero
podrán usar esta expresión del divisor
de voltaje que como vimos aquí arriba es
la proporción entre la
resistencia de abajo y la suma de las
dos resistencias así es como yo me
acuerdo de esto es la resistencia de
abajo entre la suma de las dos
resistencias si ustedes piensan que la
corriente que sale por aquí no es muy
pequeña lo que van a hacer es realizar
este mismo análisis pero ahora van a
tomar en cuenta la corriente que sale
por acá así que esto es un divisor de
voltaje